the Joe Rogan experience and I hadn't it
so I had no experience of psychedelics
until I was in my late 20s and then it
was pretty mild I had a couple mushroom
experiences that would I now describe as
aesthetic experiences right once small
doses yeah yeah I never measured as
probably one gram so I'd never had a big
trip and and there was another reason I
was I didn't feel psychologically sturdy
enough and I came of age just when the
the scare stories about psychedelics
were everywhere in the culture you know
they would scramble your chromosomes
you'd stare at the Sun till you went
blind you know the person who took all
the orange sunshine and thought he was
an orange for the rest of his life you
know these stories were out there and I
was afraid to I was just afraid yeah
well that's it's it's not an unfounded
fear oh no I know people can really get
into psychological trouble I think it's
really important that people understand
that it's a it's a profound powerful
destabilizing experience and depending
on your mindset and your and the
situation in which you take it satin
setting it can be ecstatic or horrific
and and you know there are many people
who had a series of very good trips and
then they have that one bad trip hmm and
so yeah I and I had heard enough stories
about that too to stay away so so
discovering this kind of later in life
you know I was the certainly not
something I planned on or expected it's
a great tragedy in in my opinion that
our culture has demonized these
substances and put them in this category
of forbidden fruit to the point where
you you're so nervous about doing them
you have to get them from some shady
character and you don't know where
you're getting yeah you have to do them
in the you know in secrecy you have to
be really careful but we also at the
same time are aware of all these
incredibly positive benefits from them
and then if we just had professional
places where we could go to and when we
have these rehab facilities that are
available for people trying to kick
opiates and people trying to get their
life together
but if we had something similar like a
psychedelic facility with registered
professionals who understand this and
who could evaluate you psychologically
understand if you were perhaps taking
medication that would adversely affect
your trip try to find out who you are
where what state you're at in your life
have you had any experiences before
maybe you should put you on a low dose
right let's wrap it up slowly let's try
something small and see how you react to
it and then I think I don't think people
like myself or pot smokers or people
have done psychedelics I don't think we
do it any favors either because we're
always trying to pretend that there is
no adverse effects and that there's like
you know people when they get into
something they want everybody to do it
and I've been guilty of this myself
yeah people Texas there's a there's an
occupational hazard of irrational
exuberance you know this is what
happened to Timothy Leary right I mean
it's people have an amazing experience
and the first thing they think is
everybody's got to do this yeah but it
isn't for everybody and I think you're
absolutely right I think that look that
there are risks but these are not drugs
of abuse right they're non-addictive
they're anti addictive the first thought
after having a big psychedelic trip is
not when can I do this again right whoa
whoa the last one I had it was like I
don't do that again yeah I spent that
way every time it's like childbirth or
how we here try childbirth is you can't
imagine doing it again and eventually
you do you do do it again so I do think
that we have to find the proper context
in which to do it and I think your point
is really important we need trained
guides the experience is completely
different when it's guided yeah because
you have a sense of safety there's
someone looking out for your body while
your mind is traveling and this allows
you to essentially surrender to the
experience and most bad trips in my
experience are the result of people
resisting what is happening there ego is
dissolving and it's scary it feels like
a death and they try to stop it and that
can make you very anxious and so all the
guides I worked with and interviewed
they were all like
relax your mind and float downstream if
you see a door open it if you see a
staircase go down it surrender
trust and let go and this kind of advice
changes everything and the chances of a
bad trip I think in a guided situation
are substantially less because they know
how to help you deal with it and and
what to tell you when it's happening so
I do think that by by forcing these
drugs underground and into this very
kind of unregulated use there were not
reports of bad trips were much fewer
before the moral panic about LSD in 1965
and when it was still legal you didn't
hear about bad trips you started hearing
about it when the culture did this 180
and turned against psychedelics so I
think you can create situations where
the the risks are really mitigated well
I think also the fear like you were
talking about right before the podcast
of or right as we started but some
people worried that they were gonna turn
into an orange or think they're an
orange or all those fears if you take
something and those things are in the
back of your head and your word that you
can you know literally manifest extreme
anxiety yeah that might not have been
there if you just relax and just had the
experience alone you know on its own
without all the cultural hysteria
attached to it yeah or episodes of
paranoia yeah that's that's that's
common to so but a good guide can work
you through this and actually they don't
even like the term bad trip they call it
a challenging trip because often very
interesting material comes up that you
then can work on later yeah it's like
having a nightmare and you know
analyzing it with your shrink it
actually may be very productive so so
you know I I was kind of a nervous
Nellie going into this and I really
looked at the whole risk profile and on
the on the physiological side your body
the risks are remarkably low and I'm
speaking here of the classic
psychedelics I'm not talking about MDMA
or even pot I'm really I'm talking about
LSD psilocybin which is magic mushrooms
DMT mescaline they are much less toxic
than
many of the over-the-counter drugs you
have in your medicine cabinet
there is no lethal dose which is
remarkable yeah there was one elephant
that was killed with LSD once they
wanted to see what it would take and it
was this they gave it a massive dose but
to get it to the point where they could
administer it they had to give it a
massive dose of tranquilizer so it isn't
actually clear that the LSD killed it it
may have been the benzos or whatever
they were giving you I know what a
horrible thing right go online and look
up the elephant who died from LSD a
crazy idea
yeah and wonder what is going through
the elephant's mind for it well animals
don't like psychedelics that much
[Applause]